take apart the memory into different
components the descriptive memory and
the nondescript down descriptive memory
the descriptive memory is something you
can touch out about your name but about
your ear and when will you pull what
kind of thing you learn from the class
and to the non-descriptive one it also
can be divided into different for
example how you just learn to write up I
think you can not just describe it out
but you can you can do this how you
drive a car and also the motion an
emotional one and when something or
someone just get to Andrey or catch make
you happy
this kind of a memory is no
non-descriptive one and also the
descriptive one could even more divided
into different things so different
memory may have a different mechanism to
encode them to store them the neural
activity in the hippocampus if I if you
remember hippocampus is related to the
memory and they perform this kind of
experiment are the mice about the space
memory yeah these memories you remember
the things along the way you go home
yeah yeah and as they find that the more
the neuron firing the moles are hires a
neuron activity so more is the mice
remember it's kind of place ya know
someone's opinion may contradict yours
where's my friend Alan it's all about
your perspective who are we in what is
the nature of this reality
[Music]
Nihao everybody welcome to simulation
I'm your host Alan Sathyan we are on
site in the beautiful Beijing China we
are at the picking University School of
Life Sciences we are now going to be
talking about encoding storing and the
retrieval of memory we have Bo Han Lee
joining us on the show
hi PO hi hi hi Alan thank you so much
for coming on our show
yeah thank you too for intradomain I'm
so excited for this conversation behind
we went together to the Forbidden City
to we were talking so much I'm very
excited for this you were teaching me a
lot for those who don't know Bo Hans
background he's an undergraduate student
at Peking University's Health Science
Center studying neuroscience with an
interest in learning and memory and you
can find his links in the bio below
Bohanon let's start things off by
talking to you about who you were when
you were young you were born in the
Gansu Province what's the place in China
last - wise North his Beijing is more to
the east of the China yeah and the city
actually the game's progress is really
poor and low in that he kind of economic
oh and because the environment is bad
here and the lack of water because water
is that everything - to the creatures
yeah yeah about and even the city when I
was where I was born is actually did not
exist before the 1980s because why in
white people developed and establish a
city in just 30 or 40 years because it's
because one mental volunteer the Nikko
you know the Nikko is used to make the
coin yeah the knick oh yeah is really it
was really real in China
before they find a link Oh such a a mine
in my in my city named ginger because if
you translate the ginger into English is
more like it's related to the mental
machine means the gold yeah mhm so when
they found that there was an equal mine
in my in my in my hometown and they just
ask the people as especially those ways
knowledge and young people would you
like to do to help the against province
to develop the city to develop the
northwestern China and someone just go
there and it's my grandparents how they
just get it interesting so your
grandparents went there as the city was
developing because they found nickel and
they made a nickel mine now and they
found that precious resource yeah and
then how about you know who you were how
did you pick up science your interest
anything mmm-hmm when I was at my
elementary school that's right
elementary school I am not a good
student because I don't like to do
homework even sometimes I just throw it
away and go back go out to play and also
my father tried to push me to learn the
mathematics and I was just crying
my mom was very hungry she she Acree me
on my father don't you don't you dare to
try to push push him to learn the math
mathematics because every time he tried
to push me to the mathematics I just and
I'm I'm not very happy and
sometimes I cried so but well since
different when I just entered my middle
school uh uh everything seems to work
out seems to work hard because I just
can't sit oh good great
good great and my middle school and when
when I just first to first to learn
about the chemistry I was very
interesting in that from my middle
school yeah about the second year for me
to school and chemistry ages I don't
know why but I can easily remember those
compound structures remember those
reactions yeah and also the biology is
one thing I'm also interested in at that
time but chemistry is a Muslim or most
of first one and it's a it is something
at my high school it was a chemistry and
the biology is the most autumn but the
subject I loved and actually my father
is of phasing in teachers actually I
hate physics and I'm really really bad
at physics yeah interesting so the
moments of of youth this is actually
really important for many different
people both watching as well as guess we
found on the show there's these like
pivotal moments when we're young where
we have maybe a family member that's
trying to influence us to do something
it can be both very good but sometimes
it can also be not the right path yeah
for the young person so it's good that
you ended up picking up this interest in
chemistry biology fascination with it so
then what about when you were going from
high school to picking University oh how
did that process happen just like most
of the most of the college students just
to enter the
adult examination the National adult
examination the Gaucho yeah conquer yeah
and if you get good cat great and you
could go to the University and epic
university or the chimp our diversity is
the most the most passed University in
China talk to University and I really
want to enter the university because her
university has more is more good and to
the science mathematics chemistry
physics or biology but actually my great
is not that high enough to enter the you
know the biology called all the Life
Science Center on the life science
department so I just have another option
to all enter the Sun Center or the
medical school in the University and
it's it needs a little bit low or great
than will enter here no I just engineer
and somehow I just find you alone and
anti still haze has a trust okay yeah so
then okay so while you're on an
undergraduate student you're figuring
out that okay I really like neuroscience
I want to pursue the brain you find you
long in the lab and they're working on
our science and now you're here yeah all
the time
I think I see what you're all the time
yeah yeah actually I entered my college
and I first the first year of my college
I entered
lab starting the cancer study study
study the epigenetics it's also very
it's also very good lab but I also later
about a psychology when I as my first
year a half first year and it's the
first time I get connect I know about
the psychology and really you know
inspired me and how all we can just
think about things in this way and I
just decided to major another major
another degree on the psychology one and
but when I go deeper around in
psychology when I take more and more
psychological classes I started to
question a psychology sometimes cannot
answers why I think they can or we can
describe it more a little bit as
superficial because I called psychology
one they don't go down to the newer
newer neurons they do not go down to the
south they do not go down the proteins
so I just transfer my interest from I
was weird to the neuroscience yeah
that's how I just get into the
neuroscience and then why were you so
interested with the neurons and the
neurotransmission of the neural
communication or how our brain works
why did you find this to be so
interesting why do you have found so
interesting that's a good question a
very interesting I'm mm-hmm
I need to say it's the first time I get
interested in the neuroscience or the
psychology is because of the depression
it's not me but someone else yeah and it
is
really it's a very bad experience to me
so I just so I just decided to try to
how to decided to try how to overcome
the depression the major depressive
disorder MDD yeah and actually I'm
before I answer you lost lab really I
have already learned about about the
depression and yeah but wooden I was
trying to go down deeper and I just can
find it sometimes you go to you go tween
the depression status because some kind
of a memory yeah some kind of memory
will affect you to become a depressive
one and so I just transfer my you know
interested from the depression to the
learning and memory yeah especially the
memory yeah when we see a friend or a
family member or someone that's even in
our just in our vicinity and we just see
that they're a little bit more depressed
or maybe they have major depressive
disorder that it sugars us to want to
know you know what's happening in their
brain what's happening in their life and
also how can we help them heal how can
we help them be healthier
okay so then now this has a lot to do
with what has happened in their past
that has made them feel this way and
then what is the exact neural structures
in their brain and the neural
communication in their brain that's
causing yeah there's a more neural
communications or neuro some of normally
the newer network of their brain yeah
and so then you decided that you wanted
to tackle this big challenge of
understanding the encoding the storage
the retrieval overall of learning and
memory the
is very interesting because we look
around at our world and mean we see a
chair and we wonder when did I learn
this word chair yeah
and how am i storing this word yes yeah
and how do I recall this word because
these chairs are different than if this
chair was made of wood yeah and but even
though it's a different chair it still
uses the same word yeah they have us the
same schema in our brain the chair
schema and really two different wheel
chairs around here's high chairs told
those years - yeah it's really really
also other words or other things have a
schema in our being that how we store
the schema how we just encoded into her
brain and hollis way which oh it's back
the quotes back it's really not very
clear and nowadays yes so let's start
going through some of the examples you
and I were you were teaching me about
these yes two - two days two days ago
two days ago you're teaching me about
these you said well how do you how do
you think that we remember as a kid is
something as important as 911 emergency
phone number we're like even your mom or
your dad's name you just remember these
things because they're very important
things how do we store something that
has that much importance you know maybe
we ascribe the weight of the variable as
level 90 very important out of 1 to 100
but maybe when I learn someone's name
that I might not meet again maybe
they're like the server at the
restaurant or something I may be only
ascribe level 5 yeah
to that in that way it doesn't get
encoded in store as high priority yeah
teachers about what you're thinking
about this ok and
actually I can out just a teach canto
something I know yes okay mm-hmm
people just are trying to take apart the
memory into different components the
descriptive memory and the nondescript
down descriptive memory the descriptive
memory is something you can touch out
about your name but about your ear and
when were you born what kind of thing
you learn from the class and to is a non
descriptive one it also can be divided
into different for example how you just
learn to ride a bicycle
you cannot just describe it out but you
can't you can do this how you go drive a
car and also the motion an emotional one
and when was I'm saying or someone to
schedule angry or catch you make you
happy this kind of memory is the
non-descriptive one and also the
descriptive one could even more divided
into different things so different
memory may have a different mechanism to
encode them to store them and we just
talked about okay I will little bit talk
about the emotional one not descriptive
because I'll learn something from the I
learn something about the depression
yeah mm-hmm the depression is some kind
of you if you in a definition of dsm-5
they will cause this emotional disorder
because they are just if you if you rank
someone's activity or energy and energy
from 0 to 100 most people are in the
range around the 15-pound someone just
go down to the
10 to the 5 great and they were never
it's hard for them to get them back hmm
that's a depressive you know depressive
state and it definitely the people's
personality or how gesture than how just
the environment he affected them has a
has a has a big influence on the
depression status but also also the
things the experience has also has a lot
of influence on this if someone is if
it's accessible to depression if the
personality is not strong enough and
also he experienced something really bad
when this combined together he or she
would maybe get in get in trouble get
into the depression
yeah yeah it's just from a very big
picture to see and therefore and the
people yeah if I I saw the interview you
did for yellow and hey talk about some
fda-approved drugs like serotonin SSRI
as an aria I think kind of a trusted
they are trying to target the motor I
mean pathway in our brain because some
people in the in the last century
believed it is it is a dysregulation of
mode I mean I will bring a finally cause
a cause us to be a depressive one and
yeah and also it indicates maybe the
theory is not right but it indicates
something or some networks not all of
our networks were someone related to the
nanami network may go wrong may go wrong
in were brand we just uh you know
behaved alike I just want to die I want
suicide I feel I feel nothing about have
hey I yeah just this kind of thing and
also if you if you know about Academy
mm-hmm it's some kind of a truck if you
abused it but also catch me
people find now catchman can treat
depression yeah FDA just approved
Academy has a therapeutic therapeutic
one this year just this year here and
before the ketamine was approved around
thirty their yeah
thirty years there are no drugs approved
to treat the depression yeah yeah
Academy is really mmm
you know potent or potential compound
and someone is just walking knowledge
try to make it more sleep most more
safer with no side effects on a
psychopath of other Psychopaths or some
other side effects yeah and we we've
interviewed people better been certain
psychedelic psychotherapists and they're
currently using ketamine yeah for
healing people with depression PTSD all
different types of it just it's so good
to see more and more discoveries like
that for people to be able to heal and
it comes with an assisted
psychotherapist
so someone that can help me before
during and after with the integration
and the healing you mentioned I found
this really interesting so it's is it
evident that our brain will encode and
store memory that is descriptive verses
non descriptive so if I I store a bull
hang me mm-hmm dinner table one it's a
descriptive one I store it differently
different then I store something like
how I felt when we were in the Forbidden
City yeah because my feeling when I was
there is non-descriptive yeah
build connection because the real
connection between my name and the
failing your field in the Forbidden City
because involve you know the involution
trying to push us into some emotional
animal because you don't have to
remember everything but you have to
remember something important especially
related to the danger or relate to the
happiness so if you add some emotional
element into your your the memory
process you may memory better than
normal things in it for example you are
trans trying to recite for me I'm trying
just trying to reserved words bla bla
bla bla
it's really boring with no emotion yeah
even the negative emotion in this but if
I like for me it's a was iPhone beta Joe
sure yeah forever because it's a very
important one for me it took a while
maybe me repeating it 30 times but for
me it's an important one that I
interview picking university professors
because I think it's one of those
phrases that can explain to someone why
I'm in China yeah yeah and very quickly
and also if like you were saying if we
associate when we were in the Forbidden
City if I associate the experience maybe
with the the the Museum of clocks and I
associate it with us five that were
there and and then I associate it with
maybe the smell yeah or the you have a
smell yes now the being being so yeah
we're the roast duck right or that we
had afterward the Beijing cow yeah and
so maybe the more because this is the
the memory champions we've had memory
champions on our show before and they
say that if we add sin
says like smell touchdown yeah yeah and
then we can encode and store more
effectively yeah yeah there's a very
similar - yeah even the same the same
thing because if you have something more
emotional element or some more clues
memory clues to encode one thing you can
remember it remember it more more better
yeah yeah yeah okay so then let's do
let's keep going on the example because
I think this one's this one's pretty
interesting too what's the difference
because this is probably one of the most
studied creatures the Drosophila the
fruit fly okay so the amount of neurons
we didn't Drosophila is much much lower
the amount of what we think is like
conscious experience and the Drosophila
is much much lower let me think
and so what would be our idea of some of
the differences with how we encode store
and retrieve memory versus how the fruit
fly does okay the difference between how
the millions of mammalian animals like
human are mice and in church store or
include the memory difference from the
true Sophia I was it rofo fella is Maria
on the evil even evolution and she is
very very low rank ranking and for the
mammalian for the human for the mice is
already get much higher on the
evolutionary so for for the survival of
this kind of insect like Josefina or
some other insect they may not have the
conscious used you just rip
mentioned they may not have some kind of
conscious experience he may not can
process something in their brain and
they just need to you know if if they
just smell some kind of order and when
someone chooses shock it will actually
shock to him and he will just this kind
this one is new wrong as its neurons
fire together and they're wired together
and they know okay disorder is
indication of danger so they just to
attach them together together okay then
people some people will say this kind of
this is a positive memory but I would I
was a more more not to say it's some
kind of reflex because because memory in
our brain we just to try we can we can
retrieve all the memory and we can
process our memory just like we are
watching a movie but for the Drosophila
I'm so sure whether they could do the
same thing like has we yeah and the it's
a part of the difference between the
memory mechanism between Drosophila and
a human being and also from the
structure level the Drosophila brains
where is really small has a much much
lower number of neurons but and for the
human brain all the my Springs they have
already developed or involved some kind
of brain structure is special is
specially designed to to remember things
for example hippocampus people believe
to the hippocampus is related to the
long-term memory and the for the
amygdala people believed amygdala is
associated with
related into the emotional memory yeah
but for two sofala their brain structure
is different from us yes
let's also might be the difference
between how human between the human and
the Drosophila has memory but someone
someone told me about so long told me
told us that the cells function may be
different from one species to another
species just like we have this kind of
this kind of a brain architecture and as
a Josephine I don't have this one
not the molecular the protein the air
function might be really conservative
but really be conserved through the
evolution evolution so we can also learn
about how just the Drosophila form a
memory so I told you the order of a
positive memory yep we can its molecular
mechanism and we can find whether there
is a similar same molecule seven sorry
molecule same molecule or same protein
although home log of this sacrament in
the human brain and we can just visit or
try to visit how this kind of protein or
molecule walks in a human being or in
the my spring and this might just might
provide some indicates how they just uh
yeah it's fun provide some clues yes so
so then it's although it may be that the
just brain structure itself is something
for different the molecular and protein
dynamics yeah mines may be closer to
similar yeah
as people Haas has already published a
lot of works doing unnatural Sevilla or
the Sierra Gant trying to identify how
this kind of protein or how this kind of
molecule works and because the arrogant
all the Drosophila is a very robust
genetic machine our genes are a genetic
tool to study because they grow faster
they products a lot before the for the
maizena they just give about five to ten
babies at a time and the baby needs it
needs more in certain he's about these
are the three mouths to grow into an
adult one so it if you just to do the
such kind of screening on the mice it
will take you it will take you a lot of
time I mean yeah and also the my spring
all it's very complex than the C elegans
neurons yes so you can just do this kind
of screening on the C elegans trying to
identify the elixir mechanism and
putting it back into the mice okay so is
it fair to say that when we take a piece
of a banana mm-hmm and put it next to a
fruit fly mm-hmm versus we take a piece
of a banana and put it next to the
hungry human mm-hmm that there's some
similar molecular and protein might
might be some same similar not molecular
mechanism especially because its food
its source of food which is to sustain
the body so it's like something's being
triggered within us that says if you eat
you live longer and that could be the
same thing with even all of the other
evolutionary creatures if eat live
longer so that could be some sort of
very ancient
biological feature yeah and even doesn't
even need the nervous system tool even
the bacteria yeah yeah how about when we
talk about LTP long term potentiation
teach us about what this is okay and
allow TP is some kind of some kind of
neuronal communication between two
neurons even between three neurons
actually its first was discovered on the
hippocampus slices culture slices
because in the 1950s one patient called
the page to each ham he got a damaged
are his hippocampus if I remember it
right
something just stuck into his brain and
make his hippocampus damaged or if or is
another story version that he has a
collapsing or Caesar in his hippocampus
region so the doctors just remove the
hippocampus from him and to to treat the
FCO theater and from from hey he was
from his hippocampus was destroyed hey
just cannot form long term memory just
like if you meet him and now you say hi
hm I'm Alan and after you just hit hello
Jake hands with you he will introduce
who he is and and if you just walk away
and back in five minutes later he'll you
do the same thing here with hi mhm he
would do the same thing he cannot form
which is kind of a long-term memory but
he could also remember who he is
what did he do when he was a child when
I was a young and something in the past
so people just learned about that
hippocampus is associated or related to
the form form of the GZA form of
long-term memory so so yeah and also
memory sometimes leaves if through our
entire life people believe their memory
and something can last long and yeah so
when people are first say to the
hippocampus Isis and record the LTP from
from the neurons they believe that was
this is a formation of memory yeah and
how does the LTP is induced if you
remember you can put an electrode at the
cirrie region it hasn't the Sri ca3
region your Ross has a connection with
ca1 region neurons and if you do not do
anything just put a recording actual
data say one euro and you stimulate say
it's really one house and you can just
record no more signal because they have
rehab connections so if you trigger the
upstream and downstream will have a
reflex will have a response actually but
if you stimulate the series upstream
with with 300 Hertz frequency of
electric shock or something and you can
which is abnormal for the brain research
and do not exist in the brain that
people can do this other sizes yeah and
you can record a larger signal which
really which comparators a normal one
it's larger and even it can
last fall three weeks on the culture
Noura if the culture the sizes a live
concert it's kind of signal interest so
people just named is this kind of
long-term potentiation also there is a
long-term depression if your long-term
depression is the same thing but update
on the you goes down or goes he goes up
or goes down long-term depression this
kind of long-term potentiation yeah at
that time people do a lot of this kind
of LTP on the Aplysia is some kind of a
sea snail yeah Cisneros always know
always knows your rocks under which dish
without the shell yeah well video - yeah
and yeah so then it's possible that our
memory has a lot to do with how much
stimulation we our nervous system
associates with that initial stimuli so
if we give it lots of stimulation or
lots of importance to encode there could
be the mechanism of long term
potentiation that gets activated so that
there's a greater amount of storage and
a greater amount of than ability to
retrieve or recall that versus if it's
if it's supposed to be a high level
memory that we're supposed to remember
maybe I do something that takes me a lot
of time that I'm supposed to get a good
reward for but when I get the reward
instead of having the response with long
term potentiation that's higher I don't
have that that could be associated with
depression mm-hmm it's really not
associated with the reward or not it's
it's a time-dependent thing mmm
teachers Moorea what does that mean okay
time-dependent thing yeah mmm I'm
wondering if it has to do with how fast
we get the response response
wait with in waiting million second and
very very fast really fast
and if it's delayed or not present then
the problem with some sort of mental
issue can happen there might be but
actually I am not so sure whether
there's evidence indicators yeah
if the LTP and if I you remember you'll
stimulate the presynaptic you're wrong I
said about 300 Hertz and also use
stimulate the post somatic one as a time
dependent manner you know your first
illative so firstly stimulates this and
then this one was stimulate there will
form some kind of connection and
long-term potentiation but if you first
stimulus a post some synaptic one and
then stimulates a presynaptic one mm-hmm
you know in opposite time manner yes
there will be a LTP yeah also I forgot
to introduce that the formation the
crime requirement to form LTP also needs
two neurons to work together
sorry I forgot to introduce it there is
a proof proof in the neuroscience work
together work together wire together
yeah yeah
so stimulate this and then stimulates
this one there will have a LTP formation
but if your first stimulus the post one
and
then stimulate the presynaptic one there
is kind some kind of it the are match
and they were as a signal just go too
high on the former our tt depression
this kind of depression means if you
stimulate if you stimulate the
presynaptic one and it will release last
neurotransmitters and you know you will
recount less a lower signal and also the
potential long-term potential Asian one
is it if you just really stimulate the
presynaptic neuron and suggest a normal
normal
you know normal stress and it will
release more such kind of a transmitter
neuro transmissions tank is glutamate
then it should be and so if the more
nearest major is that could mate and the
world shaker a larger signal on supposed
to one so it's it's as it is a
time-dependent one time and time yeah
yeah okay so people just try to know
also this kind of a rule that
time-dependent people believe a way
first to first to learn something and
also something to us you know a
time-dependent this kind of manner this
kind of a long to our TP just developed
and we remember this batch actually
there is a lot of evidence arguing about
LTP is now the final formation of of
memory is yes because LTP have some many
many properties like it is sometimes
it's not that robust and might disappear
but there for me the memory is still
there and also it is hard to simulate
this kind of
ltp in your network if you do this and
to to to to support it is the formation
of memory I think so there are also a
lot of hypothesis or theories like
Engram Engram cell also on any other
hypothesis the Engram is at the Engram
Engr am means the material the physical
or the chemical material of beer in the
memory it is word created in the 1920s
at one hundred one hundred ago one
hundred a year ago so people now find
that there actually had some kind of
thing like the incremented he uses word
as in the actual memory of a chair might
be literally located inside of neurons
inside of neurons or inside the neuron
communications people don't know inside
the neural network of maybe like a
thousand of that yeah or yeah and that
might have to take the activation of
that neural network in order to remember
chair yeah
and then would it maybe then be
something along the lines of my
association to objects or things or
people or whatever it may be
events emotions feelings that are maybe
more vivid they have a greater weight a
greater importance for me to remember
might activate potentially more inner
ons actually there is a science paper
published to recently indicates it is
might be the the thing you took it might
be a same thing to the record the neural
activity in the hippocampus if I go if
you remember hippocampus is related to
the memory and they perform this kind of
experiment on the mice about the space
memory yeah space memories you remember
the things along the way you go home
yeah yeah and then they find that the
more the neuron firing the moles hires a
neuron activity the more is the mice
remember is this kind of place yeah yeah
but it needs
yeah yeah hmm
we can maybe then do things like create
a memory palace with with the different
different places in order encode this
kind of associate association between
exactly mhm and that has helped me a lot
the TEDx talk I gave in San Francisco I
created a memory palace with really big
vivid things that helped me walk through
my points that I needed to recite in the
talk so it's quite possible that
depending on how much weight we ascribe
to the thing that worst in putting a
stimuli and how many emotions
associations senses that we put to that
stimuli that we can potentially be more
in control of how its encoded and stored
in our brain and then be able to recall
it better maybe we can activate more
neurons and a little bit more neural
networks activated for the recall to be
prioritized more yeah Rohan what would
you want to see happen with our
understanding of encoding storage and
retrieval of memory learning and memory
where could this go where it could help
us with our health with eradicating
disease the there are some kind of
casaya tree like PTSD anxiety depression
and even a bipolar disorder have some
kind of this kind of emotional or the
distributive component in involved in
these kind of diseases so especially the
PTSD if we can eliminate the bad memory
we can
just either they'd she treat the PTSD
and for the also there as heimer disease
the first thing that people are
suffering is they are starting to losing
their memory so if we can just finally
for one day if one day we can finally
decoding the whole memory system we can
record their memory in Chism your into
the computer or and then finally just
like in the movie wait wait wait take a
chip in your brain and away just storage
memory in that and we don't have to
worry about forgetting yeah anything
else but it's long as my master take a
lalala
yeah effort to achieve that one but
actually the recent the purpose all the
recent the how the memory research can
help us is to um actually just to try to
decode this whole system and figure out
what can how it works and the finally we
can just talk about how the application
so if you don't be if we don't know how
they works how could we just apply this
to treat it is yes yes yes okay so we
understand better how learning and
memory works then we can better tackle
things like PTSD anxiety depression we
can maybe go to the exact source of the
neural network which right now is
happening a little bit with electrical
magnetic and ultrasound stimulation and
so that can be used for healing yeah and
then we also have this long-term
potential where we can do things like
take the way that we encode memory and
can we create a similar and analog on a
computer chip of what we're perceiving
and recall it anytime these ideas of the
neural prosthetics is very interesting
and maybe we can get there it's
important for us to be morally and
ethically evolved as we get there
yeah a citation I think Asia it's really
it's a magic yes yes what would you say
is an ideal
science tool maybe like fifty or hundred
years down the line what would be your
ideal version of a tool that enables us
to solve the brain the most ideal ADA II
do too is to be the God and you see what
happens in the cell what happens in
three times what happens in the neural
networks to be the God but actually it
is not possible for us to be the God and
the soul ages to try to first from
different different levels from the
protein levels to the neuron that levels
to the network levels there are
different levels indeed needs different
type of tools and for the for the year
for the after the for the cell cell
levels yeah if you don't have it already
I think you don't have Lord to told you
we have Appa genetic tools we have the
chemical genetic tools to activate or
inhibit the neurons you know very
efficient and controllable way yes and
also we have our observation tools like
our grab sensors of the kava sniffer
developed by other groups we can record
how new wrong houses neurons work in the
physiology called condition and but all
these kind of you know this kind of
choose whatever is a participating one
or observation one they need to dig a
dig into the into the brain and bring a
little damage to the brain and cannot
apply on the human here for not there
for therapeutic purpose and for the most
ideal to I think it is less invasiveness
and the most controllable is also the
one also the thing we need to concerned
about
and the time and the spatial resolution
is also yeah things so if we can just
monitor or participating participate
neuron one thing corner on in our brain
without just a to take a hold on the
brain and this is finally the ideal list
but yeah it may take separate develop
this someone just have already developed
at the Magnum tak magnet the magnetic a
kind of tool to control the drug release
in ever brain Wow so they don't need to
you know dig into the dig into the brain
and keep light system well to stimulate
the numeron suggested to oppose a brain
you know magnify all year he and control
the drug release yes someone has already
developed it is kind of - but far from
to apply it more efficiently or in the
human yeah yeah I like that that the
ideal tool will be ones that give us
godlike powers over the brain what about
inspiring more people around the world
to work together how can we best do that
how do we just in practiced by a people
yeah
mmm actually and I haven't considered
this question before was his time and
let me think
spire
because the science sometimes the
science is really hard to push if it is
specially when you are standing on the
cutting edge of the science and one of
the member of China China Science
Academy wonder member told me is really
painful
or it's painstaking in pushing that
pushing the science and the first time I
met him he just told me this all in one
sentence and yeah and for the science of
why I think it's it's if someone's
really interested in how to do the
research to personal science age those
you know those his his fellow workers
his peers they can communicate with
large with the with each other some kind
of meeting or conference around the
world and they just try to communicate
their their sauce they communicate how
they how does a study the brain what
kind of mechanism all what kind of one
kind of you know the hypothesis they
hold and this kind of sometimes cause a
conflict all yet just kind of thing and
we'll just we'll just inspire those two
and they will oh we can we can we can
start about things in this way and that
guy is also we can we can learn things
through this kind of true like yeah so
as for other other people's around the
world someone for because for example
walkers or the other I'm not actually
too
how to inspire them and for the
neuroscience or science researchers are
saying communicate is a good way and
yeah if especially when they find
something they can work together
someone just if there is a black box
someone just because a left a part of
the black box and someone just decode
the right part if they combine together
yes because it finally decode this yes
box yes yes what would be a skill that
young people should know as we go into
the technology age one skill actually I
am not good at a computation how to to
write a program and how to get how to
write the codes and actually I think
also the math the mathematic is a
fundamental or the basic to learn or our
incre yeah tool in the computation so I
will suggest to try to make your
mathematic and or the physical knowledge
solid and trying to learn about how to
you know encode how to write the
computation compute computational
Invitational codes how to write a
program and Israel especially when you
are trying to enter the biological area
cuz this kind of ask ax attack you said
this kind of this kind of guys really
people who are desiring for because they
both know the biological saying also
know the computational say yeah they can
combine them together because you know
the when we trying to go down deeper on
the biological area information just go
just go explode and more and more
information just engage in
for us or the biological researchers we
don't know how to handle this kind of
information but if you know about the
computation science and you can oh I can
it's the establish or right or some kind
of program to find or to you know to use
this kind of information to try to find
something in that yeah there must be a
lot of you know code you have this kind
information that if you don't know Khan
computer yes yes yes interesting so yeah
our ability to see the world as
information that we can mine and
understand but we need to know math
computational science to be able to mind
that and then how about this big human
experiment that we're all a part of what
do you think is the meaning of the human
experiment I mean human yeah I can tell
what others
what other would say the meaning of
their life that form for me to actually
I'm really interested in a science and I
actually want to and also trouble trying
to version who's the sister science age
a little bit further maybe Tintin faced
alone but that's enough and for me is to
try to find something really can help
help the society or even just help the
researchers is ok we can find something
new and we stand on this new knowledge
and trying to go down deeper yeah that's
the meaning of my life I think I just
want to a simple thing I just want to
try to decode the science yeah and how
about do you think we have free will or
do you think there's determinism what do
you think yeah at the first cloth class
of my generosity ecology
P the teacher Totten taught me that the
psychology is some kind of subjects
learning the determined is determing
ization yeah because as they just have
assumptions that want some kind of a you
know behavior or something will lead to
some kind of certificate consequence so
also his behavior is affected by the
after behavior the upper just like a
chain conduction this kind of effect
yeah someone's behavior affect another
and another do another big behavior to
another one and yeah but for me I would
like to hold the free will thing yeah
for me yeah how the freewheel saying
because determine ization is kind of you
know sterben and it's just like our fate
or destiny is already been written
mm-hmm and sometimes if someone just
hold that kind of belief is better when
they are in trouble or you know poor
conditions they will say oh my life is
just like this I would also try to
struggle because the card has already
touched to me versus breaking out of it
and it's just shaving more in life yeah
yeah I was a free will and free will
thing out there trying to young what
about what do you think the most
beautiful thing in the world especially
especially and then exactly it is an
hour free no matter no matter is a human
being all the animal prey of the neurons
it's kind of you know communication it's
really beautiful just sour and Sarah has
kind of a specific unique communication
and with multiple kind of this
communication away from the network and
with multiple of this network we finally
got a brain and was just just about
while kilograms or even you know he's
more than that
and we can just compete with a
supercomputer computer
supercomputers even occupy the whole
space in this bring the supercomputer
supercomputers and if we compete
together to learn something new we will
definitely win win this game because you
know a computer also the artificial
intelligence they are just they have
already established a muncher Network
before ten years ago and there is
nothing not there's no progress on the
your network but only look at the
ability of computer to do this kind of
computation just the progresses so the
computer could learn faster but actually
only a three-year-old child can have the
have already the ability to defeat the
computer so just how how our brain
achieve this is such a little you know
little weight and a very small energy
consumption yeah yeah it's really a
beautiful thing
yeah yeah of that answer bohon thank you
very much for coming on to our show
thank you for teaching us thank you for
um and actually this is my first time to
face the very face the you know being on
the video and actually they're my first
time to have such a about one hour you
know conversation with a four II haven't
done this before this is great these
these firsts that we have together like
one hour conversation
for there is very important that one's
very important around the world for
people to have go when you go to those
countries dive into long conversations
with the people there know how to ask
good questions that's very important but
also take the risks in life you know get
on to camera one time try writing a
piece some time you do a little bit of
sign some time try taking these risks
incrementally in life I like that a lot
but I'm very proud of you you did great
thanks everyone for tuning in we greatly
appreciate it we'd love to hear your
thoughts in the comments below on the
episode let us know what you're thinking
also have more conversation with your
friends families corkers people online
about encoding storage and retrieval of
memory about the importance of studying
this about the importance of the
analogies and how we see these things in
our world have more conversations about
it check out the links below to beau
Hans work check that all of that out
also check out our links below to
simulation you can support us help us
grow help the artists entrepreneurs
organizations around the world grow you
can find our patreon PayPal
cryptococcosis feelings below and also
go and build the future everyone
manifest your dreams into the world we
love you very much thank you for tuning
in and we'll see you soon
peace good job on
[Music]